one of the first jobs I did back in the
day I was Behind Enemy Lines which was
Owen Wilson
um but my scenes were all with Gene
Hackman and you had all your scenes with
Gene Hackman yeah I mean I'm just he's
just barking orders to us but it's Gene
Hackman and you know every day I was
just like oh my gosh did you talk to him
yeah was he cool oh it's so cool so cool
he he also and I had heard rumors that
he was Gruff and cold and stuff but he
had warmed up to us we were a you know
group of you know young 20-something
soldiers or whatever and he was you know
kind of we were in this we spent a
couple days in green rooms you know
sitting with him and one of my favorite
one of my two I got two great Gene
Hackman stories do you want to hear sure
go ahead okay you can edit out whichever
um the the first one was I I met him you
know we were sitting in the room and
kind of he's warming up because he was
you know kind of in this work and a
little you know kind of standoffish at
first but it warmed up to us throughout
the day and at one point they needed
everybody in a shot except for Gene
Hackman and this actor Bumper Robinson
and me
and everybody leaves and it's Gene and
the two of us and you can I look over at
bumper and I can tell he's stewing
because he's thinking what I'm thinking
we have this one moment to ask Gene
Hackman anything this is our golden
opportunity and I'm sitting there
thinking maybe I asked him maybe ask him
about the conversation the the symbolism
of the jacket and the conversation what
did that I really you know and Bumper
Robinson goes uh hey uh Mr Hagman um
uh what was that movie you were in about
um about Bonnie and Clyde
oh no
and Gene Hackman looks at him and he
goes is it
was Bonnie and Clyde
and bumper goes oh that's right that's
right that's right that's right gosh and
I was like I'm not asking my question
now you've ruined it bumper that was our
one shot man oh my God
what's that movie you're in though oh
man oh my God and then but it was
awesome to watch him talk about acting
and how he just had a very grounded not
precious Viewpoint of it which is which
is cool yeah that's awesome you know
it's funny as we speak he's doing a
signing that he never does he hasn't and
my friend called me and said hey I'm
kind of doing the signing with him was
there anything you want signed whoa so I
ordered a Hoosiers poster and one
Superman poster and sent it to him he's
getting him signed for me dude that is
huge I mean from Indiana has to have
Alexa I mean you got it dude that is
huge right and I'm from Indiana yes come
on man oh this is so great gotta do it
so that's gonna be a new hopefully if he
gets it done hopefully you know they'll
have a shining in here I'll I'll take
some poster off but what's the other
Gene Hackman story oh the other one was
um
maybe I shouldn't be telling this one
well you don't have to no it's okay uh
uh I'm not cutting it so you you better
know okay well it's about okay so he's
old he's old no but it's about another
actor so he was so to give a name I
won't I won't name the name but he but
somebody was we were sitting there he'd
warmed up throughout the day and
somebody said hey you worked with the
so-and-so right and he and he gave he
goes uh they're like oh it wasn't uh it
wasn't a good experience
in English hey this is a big Hollywood
movie star and he shined as Gene
Hackman's smile about you know this
person and we were like oh what was it
he goes well you know how far are we
from the trailers you know like what a
hundred a hundred feet this actor
chose to that they they they were you
know they're like yeah that person's
method right and he's like I don't know
what it is but it's a waste of time you
know we'd be you know we were 100 feet
from the trailer and she'd you call to
get her horse you know
to the she she could drive her horse to
set a hundred feet and uh I remember one
time sheet she came up to me and she
said you know um Gene I got this scene
and um I'm coming down the hill on this
horse and I gotta I gotta you know my
character was uh you know abused at a
young age and uh you know that's what
made her such a so Gruff and you know so
cold and distant and uh and you know so
I I gotta you know that's all the things
and she proceeded to tell me about the
whole character history of about five
minutes she said so so what do you think
and I said
well hell if you can tell all that by
coming down this hill I'd really like to
see that
and I thought wow that's yeah that's
Gene oh my God that is just like yeah
just do the job just do the job and go
home